that's hilarious and my girl will not
play that game by the way i wouldn't
really no
no they and those are corn or flour
that's a good point it's from arowan
it's grain
uh but i think it's actually has more
weight it's paleo oh wow that's 200
worth of taxes it was twelve dollars but
i wanted to go to albertson's my uber
driver missed the exit
just cost me nine dollars [ __ ]
he's still in an uber
point you ever met this guy oh i'm the
dumb one you can't argue there's
something about me you have no idea what
you're saying gang gang
buzz bug
i had something gay guy over there at
the
starbuck today had a name prancer was
his name when they called on the cup
shocking i was like oh my gosh
they probably spelt it wrong they're so
bad at spelling at starbucks yeah that's
not the issue i don't think you think
his name being prancer it's kind of lit
yeah i guess that's true actually yeah
it's pretty good maybe it's his ig
handle though prancer
yeah
i don't know this guy rolled up on
prance of the prince i mean he
definitely
attracted fella oh if you tickle this
dude some sparkle would come out of them
sweet load pop right out oh this guy had
really
full tank
i bet his sweat tastes like other men
[Laughter]
what was his order huh what was his
order i think it was like a um some kind
of a coffee something like that like
he had some sort of i feel like it was
like an iced vanilla latte extra shot
dude
you need to chill wait that's my order
i knew it
with oat milk
yeah it's mark's the big-ass prancer
um
[Music]
yeah i think
oh no he's it was like whipped cream it
was like i think it was just triple
whipped cream yeah just whip whipped
cream yeah that makes sense full of
whipped cream
just a bendy cup of wicker yeah yeah
just the gay strength of the world you
never know man a lot of guys out there
will stop by starbucks just to get
um
also they're socializing a lot of people
don't have any socializing in los
angeles and so they will stop by there
just have a moment of socialization big
time
and now i feel like you stopped by their
maybe chat with some friends huh i mean
i see some people outside the window but
i don't
you well you can definitely tell if a
man is gay based off his drink order
yeah i think you got any friends or
those pumpkin spice lattes they like the
way they taste oh yeah pumpkin spice
lattes for for college girls and gays
man
you're an idiot
it's facts
bro bro you don't even know you're an
idiot
what i'm saying is i don't know maybe
you don't know you're gay dude if i was
gay bro i would be dating a lot of
[ __ ]
men normal wishes okay you're fighting
it look and you're losing it's the third
round it's ten to nine bubba
well it's about 900 to zero but i've
dated a lot of women okay but
i'm just saying if i was gay dude i'd be
the first person to know bro
you know
and i'm not i even remember like they
say if you're gay if you write i'm gay
with your left hand then it'll be you or
your opposite hand you'll be able to do
it clear like oh it looks the same yeah
and you can't do that
all right well that solves this but
the problem is how [ __ ] goes all over
the page like this
which is pretty good
so
but uh
yeah man that's like one of those old
things if you do this you know you write
with your left hand and it's exactly how
you write it with your right or whatever
you're true but yeah it's like yeah it's
like you're your own you can be your own
ouija board
now a little birdie told me by little
birdie i mean a huge birdie told me you
were at dinner last night with mr spade
oh yeah we went to get some food last
night his birthday's in like a month
so we went early you know he's getting
older well you guys are busy too yeah
anyway he's getting older so it's like
he gets that er he wants to go early you
guys went to a uh like a hollywood place
where we were talking about he went to
boast
see that's my first answer my
ex-girlfriend used to work over there
she was hot still that's hot
um
and
yeah what was over there oh jelly roll
was over there he's like because he came
straight from there to here yeah i just
saw your boy
what the hell's he doing gotta love
jelly roll baby most malone they call
this him alone
i love seeing him man malone max yeah
well he just i mean you see jelly roll
he just uh
you know you just damn love him he's the
fifth season man yeah he's just a big
hug oh he looks like you could just
[ __ ] hide in him if the cops came
yeah
he looks like people are hiding in him
and that the cops are looking for him
you just hide him under his
they're like uh have you seen so and so
and you just hear an echo inside of
jelly roll it's like tell them no
dude jelly roll was on jimmy kimmel and
he he wasn't complaining he's like i
didn't know he's like when you go on
you're hoping like the rock is on or
kevin hart or something like that he
said i can't tell you the names of the
people that were on with me man yeah you
know you finally get there and he
thought he was gonna have like you know
spade or something like that
he said he goes man i can't pronounce
the names of these people who are one
illegal aliens probably
that's kimmel man didn't jimmy kimmel
either he's a blackface guy right yeah
he did car malone back in the day and
then he wants to try and cancel
everybody and get all woke
yeah dude wasn't he the man show dude
who was bouncing titties around [ __ ]
using that
thing yeah jesus christ
[ __ ] fraud yes even if he was in
white face imitating carl malone that
guy impregnated a 13 year old girl so
malone did yeah the mailman likes no one
talks about it yeah he delivers mail
early catch my drift oh yeah
he
has a child with a 13 year old yeah yeah
and then he might be 14 but it was yeah
she was 14 right and then how old was he
though
20 something
over 18. yeah because then he went to
college they had another kid in college
and then that son
doesn't talk to him because he wasn't
around but he's he's a baller i think he
played for georgia football
carmelo is just making deliveries man
malone baby we're malone heavy into this
that's awesome though jelly roll
yeah jelly roll
general blowing up man he's doing good
man mainstream yeah i think he was just
probably excited to go do it
you know i i don't what did he say he
said yeah they had fun bunny was with
him
you know yes girl he's lady
bunny and she really
she's easy on the eyes
i bet she's easy on the hands too she's
got some tits on her
great line daddy she's got two of the
coolest tits i think
first team all tits yeah and she crushes
on only fans
yeah i don't know what kind of stuff
they're doing sure you don't know
everybody knows you have accounts dude
you have sub accounts you have other
accounts bobby has accounts in your name
[Laughter]
we all know you have [ __ ] accounts on
there
okay
whatever the [ __ ] you guys have going on
whatever you guys have going on is
[ __ ] [ __ ]
jesus christ it's like the shittiest
game of clue i feel like
you and bobby and kalyala are in the
shittiest [ __ ] game of clue this game
sucks yeah dude
oh yeah she is the looker though
yeah both of them are really cute
actually i said this jelly roll's a
handsome guy he's and he's just so
lovable you just damn love him you know
oh yeah he can't help but love him god
god get her off the screen jesus christ
straight path see what this guy has to
say yeah here comes the guy who [ __ ]
set up the email account
[Laughter]
king the sting in the wing
[Music]
just wanted to give a shout out trailer
park hacks
so
we were boxing up stuff getting ready to
move
our mixer
is in storage
so
we busted out mixer
black and decker
egg beater
go get some
things to be intense yeah the black is
doing most of the beating i bet
trailer park scramble there that guy's a
good guy
yeah
i don't know
he's lying about them moving though i
don't think they own i don't see
anything boxed up my man
place looks like a pigsty it is
cluttered
is it yeah that means [ __ ] everywhere
man
it's blm dude they're all doing this
kind of [ __ ]
i mean so he's using a [ __ ] electric
drill to mix up the eggs for the whiskey
a little yeah a spoon and get it done
daddy i mean those eggs are easy don't
be such a [ __ ] dude i think that this
guy's a great guy
i think this dude could easily be like a
mechanic or do something fun like that
it's obviously he can take care of his
family he's not going to be have his son
see him beating an egg with a spoon like
some [ __ ]
i don't know if i didn't see any kids
man but that place is sanitary you said
use a spoon dude dude just like this
what just like this
yeah they're eggs bro
prancer over here ordered this morning
i'll tell you that rob prancer and still
ordering dude the pumpkin spice latte
brendan you can't use a spoon of beet
eggs dude that's why you think you need
a power tool though you'd still be in
the ufc if you didn't use a spoon if you
dude dude do you think you need a power
tool though
do you think maybe you should hit the
gym if you need a power tool and mix
three eggs
that's fair yeah i agree yeah you don't
need to bring in electricity to do it
okay i agree yeah this dude i don't know
if you need to do a cycle of death that
they [ __ ] spin your egg still you
know
i agree this dude's cutting corners with
a [ __ ] hacksaw
but i don't know if a spoon is the way
to beat an egg dude that is a mating
call for gay men
looks like he uses a whisk
just like can you whisk it
hey chris let's take a little break yeah
good boy i was getting tired i want to
talk to you something about bluenile.com
oh yeah cause i'm looking for jewelry
yeah okay well this is the original
online jeweler to high income adults
that's a hundred k plus primarily males
25 plus looking to get engaged or gift
fine jewelry to
why don't you guys visit the website and
convert into a blue nile customer does
it have to be engagement rings oh i see
fans that's hilarious they have fine
jewelry diamond jewelry little cocktail
rings gemstone necklaces for your mans
or your girl what yeah
both so uh
dude i got they sent my girl uh some
rings man she wears them every single
they're beautiful right yeah they're
dope you could flaunt that stuff she
didn't get rob whatever uh listen make
your moments sparkle with the jewelry
from
bluenow.com use code k-a-t-s that's code
cats plus every order is insured ships
free and arrives in discreet little
package so it doesn't give away the
surprise shop stress free and find your
forever piece go to bluenow.com today
promo code cats
that's that real [ __ ] chef you still
seen your girlfriend chin
you want me to answer that
can i answer tin
you can ask her uh no really yeah they
broke up yeah it sucks recently
um a few months ago three months ago wow
single ready to mingle gender she was
she was a very close friend before he
dated so it's kind of a it's an awkward
are you guys still friends or not right
now i'm not gonna be friends right now i
can't later yeah later jesus living the
life though thanks
i didn't know man why'd you bring it up
you're just curious i was just he said
chin i looked over at chin i'm like what
what do i know about chin that's going
on with him yeah oh his girlfriend i
remember the fishing girl yeah fish and
girl and did you guys so i was like oh
how's your girlfriend doing i appreciate
that then yeah chin's been getting out
man he went to jelly roll concert yeah
solo having fun i saw you in browser
over there yeah dude it was amazing dude
i was telling you guys he's like a
superstar
you know i know it's
from
oh save me
he's good man good and the [ __ ] guy
that he introduced to me what's this
dude teddy swims incredible singer do
you know him yeah i've never seen him he
went viral for all he showed me last
night holy [ __ ] he was there last night
he was at joey's concert he was at the
green room with us all of us was he
singing in the green room no but we
wanted him to do god dog he is talented
yeah yeah teddy's good man you know
after seeing all these guys blow up like
this theo we need some face tats dude
and let's put on some weight
little face tats grow some beards i've
got so many problems
you don't need to add that to the plate
yeah the last thing i would need is that
dude i think for me you should get it
though
get something dude i might get someone
yeah you're considering it right yeah it
does look good give your wife another
reason to be pissed brendan
hey when you go with a misspelled word
on your head
unbelievable it's this room you get
something like that
[ __ ] emojis
jesus christ and what is this guy doing
speaking of beards yeah this could be
anybody just a filter it looks like a
filter that's eric griffin probably
trying to get more money
that's the new bank of america filter
[Laughter]
this is cody from phoenix and i guess
this is the king and her stinging for
theo
human skulls theo talked about an
opportunity that he had to purchase a
human skull and bought a candle instead
a few weeks ago i was out to eat at a
restaurant in phoenix after the
restaurant we went into a little novelty
store next door
and lo and behold you can purchase human
skulls from the store
they have a human body you can purchase
the entire skeleton so king are stinging
at human skulls theo here's your chance
to redeem yourself
buzz buzz sore where's authentic at
i think
is it legal to sell all this [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] dude it's biden times
dude yeah you write inflation this is
what's going on dude skull six grand
thanks buying for inflation also my boy
marcus searched the dark web before he
fighted a nice human skull for really
200 bucks ain't that right margaret
you've sell one for 200 on there oh
we'll find them if you want a high
quality one but if you want to go maybe
something like 80 90 bucks oh yeah
that's what i want yeah
i want one that still smells like
downtown you know
we definitely make that happen
yeah i was wondering do you get any
vertebrae with them
with a skeleton uh yeah how much some
ribs i want my nice little rib cage yeah
you if you put it all together you get a
discount but the vertebrae is 30 i've
seen and individual ribs are 15 to 20
depending on the size of the person who
wants one rib
yeah and i need a i need a full rack
give me a slab human slab
i don't know you know there's some pervy
little gay dude out there that's putting
one rib in his butt yeah you're right
they make it almost impossible not to
get the full skeleton three grand for
the skull six grand for the the full
thing you know i know theo's gay because
i can't get that tail bone
[Laughter]
dude i'm not being with no
skeleton man dude six g's though it's
authentic [ __ ] that can't be legal
here's what family member signed off
like yeah put in the pawn shop i would
for six g's like hell what do you
otherwise you gotta pay to bury it you
keep it above ground and you bend it to
someone make a little hustle
six grand for a skeleton and it died
that even look like they it matters if
you have all the parts or not
it can't be legal they have tape on the
ribs yeah why is it orange huh well
that's like well how is that gonna stay
up man that's the cartilage
i'm not sure let's zoom in on that a
little bit can we see
uh
i don't want the one with this the
[ __ ] ski mask on it
that one's got a little bit of skeet on
the front huh
now when the teeth are all [ __ ] up i'd
negotiate a better deal
yeah why is it
it could be they could have done a
candle thing
yeah the orange it's just to hold it
together man so get the look come on i
don't know if that could be fat or
something i don't know how your ribs
hold like what's that cartilage man
are you sure are you guessing i'm sure
you ever you're torn a rib or broken rib
takes forever to heal because the blood
flow through there i never torn a rib
because my ribs aren't made out of
fabric you can you can tear the solid
shine you can tear it that holds it like
between the ribs you can tear that
daddy's torn that takes forever daddy
has
my father died when i was 16.
i'm sure he tore his ribs as well at his
age
what's this gentleman want to tear his
eyes out if he knew we were on this show
what's going on guys got a debate club
for you what do you want to see more
that elvis hitter
or that barbie quitter
personally i would love to see elvis the
pelvis
the king of rock and roll himself
rather than some blonde bimbo barbie
that's just what i think
what do you guys think
gang gang buzz buzz
sore barbie's for chicks
work so i gotta go do do do
barbie's for chicks dude unless you're a
straight man then you like chicks i like
barbie you're gonna go to barbie wait
who's barbie is that no it's margot
robbie
all right probably
but the elvis stuff's cool what was some
weird [ __ ] i'd whistle for those tits
from the back all the time
let's see those kids yeah because barbie
had titties but then the the when it
comes to the privates like especially on
ken the ken doll it was just smooth well
they got gosling that kind of makes
sense he doesn't seem like he has a dick
on him
oh wow you're not gosling fan huh oh i'm
a fan but he doesn't seem like a dude
imagine his dick
fair point hard to do yep hard to do
now this is
well he got jacked he has shred city but
he's also how tall is he he's a small
man he's small margot robbie i've seen
in person jesus christ
she looks like the same species
she's hot oh my god distractingly
that was a unicorn man i don't know i
don't know if i believe what you're
saying i'm saying her and kate back and
sale only people i didn't think were
human when i saw him in person really
yeah
beckon sales bang like half of the
comedians you know
wow that's hot
she does she loves she loves young
comedians she's a pete davidson
i can't name another one
oh no uh rife
yeah yeah i think who else some other
guys
i was too old to ever get a chance at it
yeah we're too old man we need some
straight yeah it's like that kevin
spacey [ __ ] i wasn't too old to get
molested though as a child
it started dark dude yeah first team all
dark man uh elvis i heard is really
really great i just heard it's like kind
of more like a musical than a movie have
you guys seen either one i haven't seen
either one i don't think are either one
out yet i just saw elvis last night did
you enjoy it uh yeah but there was like
it was way too long it was two hours or
38 minutes because there was so much
music
but um
are you an elvis fan uh i mean i don't
know a ton about him but like yeah he's
good and it was cool i think he did a
really good job they started to play
videos at the end of elvis and like like
real videos yeah at that point i was
like oh [ __ ] what am i watching like he
really you don't realize how big of a
like he was massive back in the day
what's interesting about him too is his
manager uh there's a story on his
manager who royally [ __ ] elvis that's
what the movie's about yeah yeah oh oh
i'm sorry the movie is the book on his
manager's [ __ ] him do they talk about
how because in the book they talk talk
about how the manager didn't have a
passport you know did a legal [ __ ] or
whatever i think it was german but uh he
couldn't leave the state cause can't get
back in so elvis got these crazy
international offers like tour and build
his brand but he was like no that's not
good for you because he couldn't go he's
like why don't you stay in vegas
and everybody knows like elvis hated
vegas and wanted to like if he was in
one spot he'd start doing drugs oh yeah
so they were saying a lot of his drug
abuse started in vegas because he hated
being there all the time like doing
shows non-stop they're like if he just
had a different manager probably still
would have died but you know it should
happen doug
i can i wouldn't listen to what you're
saying but i'll say this dude i think
that
this
um
i think that i did hear this and i was
listening what you're saying i'm sorry
it's okay but i did hear this i'm
telling that story for a reason because
you know
you know
you know
what is it you're you know i'm just
trying to say like you know the managers
can take advantage of people oh you got
to be smart man
yeah yeah and if you're in one place you
could start doing drugs
i was hoping that story was just
probably dude no everybody else in the
room is good i don't have a manager and
i did drugs
so i can't relate to that guy i can't
relate this guy being misled by someone
else when he has his good old-fashioned
self to [ __ ] himself up no one's getting
50 of theo's [ __ ] up
but i will say this they said that like
six things that happened in that movie
didn't even really happen in real life
that they fabricated so much of it so
that's so bizarre yeah it's a movie
though that was the first thing i did
when i got out of it i was like like
fact checked it and there's this yahoo
article and like i love doing that it
was just all embellished and stuff like
like he signed a contract with that
manager and in the movie they were atop
a ferris wheel that the guy made stop
and like that's the kind of [ __ ] they
made up but like i mean the whole [ __ ]
about the manager that was in the book
that was there and it was good and i
didn't know did they show his funeral
like even at the funeral the manager was
trying to wheel and deal other [ __ ]
because even though he's dead he was
trying to get more money out of the
family they said he made some crate like
a 200 million dollars off elvis
nuts yeah might have been 600 million
something's crazy
yeah and he was in debt to whatever
the international hotel which
elvis had the residency and that's why
he
pushed him there yeah pushed him because
his dad he's like i'll bring you elvis
he was just a piece of [ __ ] man who was
the guy let's bring him up but but but
that stuff like with the embellished in
the movies it's like blindside remember
the the the poor black in the sandra
book takes on her wing and gets drafted
in the [ __ ] nfl he hates that movie
he's like
there was nothing like my life man
that's what the black guy said yeah oh
yeah what's his name uh
that's in there he looks shady
tom hanks played it yeah wow oh wow that
was a looker huh you ever seen him fresh
off the the army reserves man looker you
just look at that guy but he's gonna
make so much money i mean people don't
look like him man nuts
leading people on what are you looking
at men yeah hell yeah i'm looking at men
look at chicks dude they're better
looking no look at him dude look you
that guy gets off the [ __ ] boat
you're like holy [ __ ] dude let's head to
hollywood my man
it's not like that manager had a talent
how tall was elvis
ooh good question does this could change
i know when he died he was like 300
pounds
six foot wow perfect you dude he would
snap that dick though
great height johnny cash was six two i
didn't know that i was shorter
i'm more of an elvis fan named johnny
cash
johnny cash was a i think he had a
little bit more satan in him oh he had
all the darkness in him
wow willie nelson's a small ball huh
shortstop
willie nelson looks like he smells
alright what's this guy want nick
yo
theo brendan chris eric what's happening
zach barrett coming at you from west
palm beach florida i
got a little debate club for you boys
today i was down the rabbit hole last
night pretty deep on youtube and came
across a couple weird mma fights want to
get your take on them
one was between two guys neither of
which had any arms
so a ton of kicks being thrown the
entire time
and the other was actually a grandfather
and his grandson
against a heavier russian woman fighter
so i'd like to get your take on that
which you'd rather buy the pay-per-view
for uh gang gang buzz buzz soar
now i'd assume these fights are either
in russia or to rough and rowdy by the
bar stool boys yeah they were definitely
overseas the russians do some wild [ __ ]
they do like medieval times they'll be a
full [ __ ] armor stabbing each other
and [ __ ] you ever seen these black
russians that they just came out with no
scary
russian and black dude
game over it's a wrap yeah it's a rap
dude dude your boy mike perry is one
lost away from [ __ ] fighting some fat
russian though i'll say this mike
perry's gonna beat that guy's ass
michael venom page yeah you want a bet
on it michael vivian pages says that
sneaky cat punch dude yeah yeah you want
to bet on it
michael perry's gonna find some way to
beat that no doubt you want to bet on it
i don't know if he can knock out mike i
don't know if he can knock out michael
perry though
with that little cat look it's a little
cat no i know it's he's so easy to
figure out if you want to pet you let me
know my man and you just have him on the
show so you're high and right listen i
love mike perry i don't know who the
[ __ ] i'll bet on this
brain cells wait oh man idea
[Laughter]
[ __ ] bro you should choke us out
that one guy's titting out a little huh
yeah looks like he has some dino a
little bit i love how the one dude has a
nice patch on his back
you don't have any arms let's just
straight to the heart bro is the deal no
takedowns no signal dude look yeah this
is your idea
and then this is a grandpa and a
grandson
oh my that's the grandpa oh yeah it is
there's julia michael
like a 75 oh wow eighteen year old son
she's [ __ ] up gold this [ __ ] is well
look at the grandpa dude the grandpa is
75 bro dude grandpa's out of his mind oh
nothing can fight
dude this russian girl is beating their
ass there's ben askren versus the island
boys
damn
what would i rather watch uh listen even
after 20 seconds the guys with no arms i
got pretty boring because i'm not very
good at kicking either i'd rather watch
this this old russian
hag beat up this
weird takashi it seems staged to me
though didn't it seem staged a little
bit a little bit yeah yeah like the
guy's hair just seemed like too much and
he's like
yeah i just fell down he's kind of
backpedaling from the start she seems
like she can kind of fight and they just
are complete morons
they look like they took this fight for
ketamine you know what i'm saying like
they're just
yeah definitely this looks like a k hole
somebody went down that's exactly i
don't want to watch either of these
dumbasses that's the name of the
organization
hole fighting hey where is this florida
army
oh that's what's her name dude i met at
dinner one time chanel west coast
what the [ __ ]
i was like was she talking about
you you met chanelle wesley no she looks
like kate upton she does yeah dude
dang and i am up a ton
yeah i like that brendan
[Laughter]
where's like hey guys my name is caitlin
um i'm from a fairly small town called
covington georgia you have probably
never heard of it yes i have that's
where they filmed in the heat of the day
i talked about in the heat of the night
a few times on the podcast and that was
actually filmed in my hometown and
that's like the only cool thing to ever
really happen there but i do have i
guess maybe it could be like a debate
club it's more like a question um but
let me preface it with a little
backstory i went to theo show in augusta
a couple weeks ago
and while i was there this guy
approached me and oh yeah
before even saying anything well i do
have like a big tattoo on my arm so
that's kind of important to the story
but before even saying like introducing
himself he just starts blurting out
questions about my tattoo um what does
it mean
how long did it take how much did it
cost but nine times out of ten when a
guy approaches me in public that is the
line he uses so
i guess my question for you guys is when
you were approaching a woman out in
public or you know trying to pick up a
woman how how were all doing it what
were you saying and what we're all
thinking
i'm not using cheesy pickup lines like
it's the 90s just talk to mike's goddamn
human but her her tattoo must be a real
eye catcher because someone's just
coming up like man sweet ink that's
that's the you know the guy's probably
kidding me at theo's show [ __ ] goes
up sees her cat she's probably staring
at it yeah so he just started blurting
out about her ink
it could have been me
that's what i'm thinking elephant in the
room it sounds like a steel
yeah
it could have been me
about some guy named prancer all night
i mean i think look a couple things one
that this girl seems like a beautiful
girl
and that southern belle oh yeah i could
easily see she's got some real look like
dandelions or ukulele uh not useful
but what are those called eucalyptus huh
eucalyptus no
no flowers uh you owe uh gladiolis maybe
hold up a gladioli if we can those are
daisies
but she's got that real wagon bro yeah
she looks like she has a wagon
yeah shut that cracker bill she got that
nippled freaking
biscuit gravy am i right
damn she got that little monkey hanging
out right there beautiful lady seems
like a good lady oh those are gladiolis
yeah yeah i don't see any of those on
there but there's some dandelions
i was just in uh
i was just somewhere
um this lady seemed like a great woman
what did it say she went to
college due to the comedy show king
you're staying at college
[Laughter]
uh what's a good line the tattoo thing
look i definitely fall into the guy that
comes up with the lamest lines i think
except for one time dude um i had a
really good one but the girl didn't like
it but it was still good what was it do
you remember
she oh this girl got on an elevator this
cute girl and i um and i've been seeing
her downstairs in the lobby of this
hotel and i was like oh man if i see her
again i'm going to say something right
and so she got in the elevator and there
was some dude was in there right some
guy was in the elevator he was listening
to the podcast when i got in the
elevator he's like no [ __ ] way it's
like a prank show or something and i was
like what's what's up and he's like oh
i'm listening to your podcast right now
i was like oh man that's crazy wow and
then the elevator stops and this girl
gets on
and uh were you like what did you say
you were listening to over there
well the dude was still like hey man
yeah i'm a big fan or whatever so this
girl's overhearing it right so it made
me feel like excited at least like yeah
that this kid cared he's a nice kid
seemed like a decent kid pretty tall
and then uh
i she i said what are you here for and
she's like i'm here for a wedding
and um i was like do you need a uh
plus one uh yeah you need a date for it
aggressive pepper sprayed that's dope
yeah yeah aggressive but how about you
and she goes
no i'm good no i don't need one you know
and that was it and then i got off and
uh
and that's when the kid was saying oh do
you know who that guy was and as the
elevator doors you could see i saw this
look in her eyes like oh she [ __ ] up
no it was a look that she made the right
decision
and you were like this
you were like this
okay yeah my whole body was getting
skinnier as the doors were closing just
so she could see me that's not creepy at
all you're just there waiting no but i
had this look in her eyes and i knew for
the couple floors that that thing went
down that she knew in her head that
she'd made the right decision or really
[ __ ] up made the wrong decision no
she was short but her hair was the
longest hair you've ever seen it was
larry down to her [ __ ] ankles so
they're you know everyone's getting
water or something i'm working out and i
just went you have long hair
oh what she turns around no dude she
turns around what i go you uh your hair
is crazy long shoes yeah
no [ __ ] i was like that's all i got
she was like have a good day i was like
yeah she's like you have long marriage
is just crazy you have a big nose thank
you thank you hey have a good day oh
that's a dude oh talking to girls is
always the hardest thing to do she's
talking like they're [ __ ] humans i
talked to some girl out front here about
therapy for a [ __ ] an hour they just
she was starting she's like hey you are
right but yeah i'm fine why she's like
you know i just i can feel i'm like see
a therapist and then she was like yeah
and then dude was therapy talk for
[ __ ] an hour you're like you know oh
that's mole yeah that's your whole
probably me with the kids are you out
there dude it was you yeah
and you're the one with the long hair
here i am right here
[Laughter]
shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] oh wow
great team with respect oh
gang gang [ __ ]
that's all
that's all of us in one person i think
yeah the person's only point was that
look like chris in the future but he
also looks like theo and they say gang
gang
yeah i think that's a good mix right
there
seems like this guy
yeah
it could be italian or quidditch
it could have a a long [ __ ] track
record
what do you mean
you tell me this guy looks safe
i don't feel safe
yeah that guy seems like a
but i don't know once you kind of start
to i mean that guy looks like a cr guy
looks like his wife just
like dick i don't know it looks like his
wife's in a fridge
yeah
yeah i feel bad
but yeah it looks like his wife is
basically leftovers yes
yo what's up brandon chris theo nick
eric
can't forget you
yeah you want that king to sting it for
you
logging
oh yeah
currently destroying our environment one
forest at a time
that's what everyone else thinks anyways
just trying to make a dollar
in this uh terrible economy as people
say preach um
what are your thoughts there's not a lot
of that going on where you all are now
we're bringing it never seen a logging
operation
but
i'm curious to know what y'all think
brendan
thank you for the addiction
and my wife's pissed
but
either way
that's great buzz buzz
sword
welcome to the fam son
doing that yeah
man just taking down trees this guy's a
great guy i think man obviously he's out
there logging here's the thing people
some there are people right now sitting
in a building made out of wood
complaining about wood bro yeah man
logging though dude this man needs to
watch fern gully that's how this ends
really yeah dude what avatar the entire
thing they're trying to take down the
trees
it doesn't end well
but look i mean i think if we could make
a fake wood that we could build houses
out of we wouldn't need trees we can
we easily can yeah there's all that [ __ ]
well then why are they still doing it
have you ever seen the huh why are they
still doing it
money
has to be a money play right real wood
i don't know have you ever seen the
those the the crazy uh environmentalist
people that uh chained themselves to the
trees
that what themselves to treat they
literally chain themselves to the trees
so they can't cut it and all they do is
cut around them so there's just one tree
or they cut their arms off and those
guys end up fighting yeah
yeah that could be what those guys
they're fighting each other what are
they doing with wood still chin bring up
real wood
or wood uses common wood uses today okay
but
he's pulling up common uses but bamboo
bamboo flax him bamboo tough as [ __ ]
there's a hundred tree species that's
why i see pandas just chewing all the
[ __ ] time
it's a tough meat
well tree meat
why are why are we using wood if we
don't need it there you go fuel okay
pulpwood
construction furniture
other art
sports and recreational equipment
i do like a nice wood flyer myself so we
have fake meat now but we still use real
meat
but i haven't seen a lot of fake wood
have you guys you can buy fake wood
floors like they're way cheaper and
they're actually better
hmm
you're safer
yeah
you're
so okay so if they have fake wood then i
think we got to start using more fake
wood
a lot of houses are i mean think about
it they made uh new gas stations illegal
in california so it's gonna be you know
we're going electric here
gonna be fake wood yeah wait two people
start getting electrocuted while they're
driving yeah dude think about it oh dude
like fake meat fake tits that's
california nutshell
fake wood fake meat
fake tits so you want alternative you
say sting it
vlogging
look dude i think logging is good look
i'll tell you it depends on what's going
on i'll tell you this you can log that
tree that's outside of my apartment
where all those birds are always
chirping every morning waking you up
when i'm trying to recover from being
high on cocaine
okay
so freaking
dropped off two birds in my yard every
time he [ __ ] came by you know it's
gonna keep you up all night this piece
of [ __ ]
all right it would be unbelievable the
guy that guy had two i swear he had to
get two warblers out there bro and maybe
maybe it was just some exotic bird like
two [ __ ] two cans like oh two cans in
[ __ ] l.a
um what is this what is this guy i think
with the the log in the the tree logging
too it's it's getting dicey in like
brazil and [ __ ] because they're tearing
down the amazon and stuff like that
in the states a little different but
elsewhere it gets it gets a little dicey
we started turning down [ __ ] the
amazon we got problems
you think i mean i'm not disagreeing
with you look i think we need as much
nature as we can get the the thing is
though some of these places some people
bought land a long time ago and put
forests on it to cut the forest down so
it's based like somebody doing a crop of
something right
i think there's a difference if you're
just rolling out through a national park
that's what i'm saying right that's
insane if you're just running through a
national park at night with a chainsaw
that guy's out of his if you're on molly
cutting down trees and joshua tree you
got a [ __ ] problem man naked yeah
it'd be fun though huh i mean
no i don't want to be naked around a
[ __ ] chainsaw dude that's one of my
biggest fears
because i did chainsawing with a guy
big uh ronnie
and he had a mental disability and was
just about to start cutting the wood out
there and he lined it up on my leg bro
as a joke no
and i was like oh my god ronnie i was
like that's a that's my leg man
that ain't a log right
my bad my own like number seven lakers
and seven let's see
he called me cat daddy all the time and
said lakers and seven i love this guy oh
let's give him as a third guy on the
show oh ronnie was good bro
ronnie would be good man i don't know if
he's still alive or not probably not he
had some of this because he's still
playing that with [ __ ] chainsaws and
cocaine oh they know yeah it's a bad
combo have you ever seen scarface he and
i shouldn't have been working together
he was a good worker he just uh
he needed severe instructions probably
not trustworthy huh
he
instructions but also probably should be
handling the chainsaw we were working
for four dollars an hour well he said
you want me to do you want me to do this
saw and i said yes and that's where i
messed up yeah you should turn the
second yeah the second i knew i saw him
with and i was like this isn't good you
put on your leg oh yeah
he's the kind of guy that would beat
eggs with a spoon
[Laughter]
he's probably trying to shave some
[ __ ] slices off that ass but he would
win though he was he was a strong guy
his name was big black guy yeah yeah
ronnie i think was his name funny cat
daddy oh yeah
daddy cat daddy that's all he would say
all day laters and seven cat daddy it'd
be fun to have men here and eric sitting
over there yeah
oh yeah dude he's got he's way blacker
than eric yeah
this guy's one of our favorite
submitters he's got uh kinder
third or fourth submission right yeah
this guy looks like if the guy from the
mask got totally better
and it looked great yeah
cocky dennis
what a penis thing it is noah from
nashville i've got a king it or sting it
for your [ __ ] ass
uh
the tortilla challenge
it's uh going around on tick tock right
now
it's basically
you and your hoes
slap each other around with some
tortillas
and you try not to laugh try not to
chuckle it up
and i'd like to see if you [ __ ] can
do it
and uh i want to see you put some money
on it stop being so cheap and do some
real [ __ ] for once yeah and um yeah
let's see what's up let's get some
chainsaws and tortillas in this store
sing it up
i do like his demeanor dude
this is the so they get to the water or
something you need to talk about the
part where you have to put
yeah you just slap them with a [ __ ]
fresh tortilla with water in your mouth
and the first person to spit it out oh
that'd be fun as [ __ ] dude he just
slapped the [ __ ] out of his girls i
think you guys should put a thousand
dollars at it
dude this be hilarious
we have tortillas
what
i'm out
i've got enough issues at the moment
shannon brandon
well i think we are doing threes yeah i
think you need a squad to really do it
that's why i'm saying we need a squad it
can't be me chin mark and nick maybe do
we film it after the episode just put it
at the end put it in
there
smack someone that's hilarious hey my
girl would not play that game by the way
i wouldn't really no
no they and those are corn or flour
that's a good point it's from arowana
it's green
but i think it's actually has more
weight it's paleo oh wow that's 200
worth of
it was 12
i wanted to go to albertson's my uber
driver missed the exit he [ __ ] me just
cost me nine dollars [ __ ]
he's still in an uber
[Laughter]
gets into every uber he's like hey can
you take me to vols volkanovsky in under
two and a half rounds
uh
i like ubering i work on the way here
i'm always whatever you tell yourself
[Laughter]
dude also my girls mexican they [ __ ]
worship tortillas she's not gonna make a
joke out of it she would throw you out
of a house for these for those weird
hemp tortillas you brought they're heavy
as [ __ ] though we need to get some more
blacks on this show you got eric oh yeah
like i said
who's blacker you think chin or eric
chin wasn't a gang i was never in a game
he keeps denying you were dude i was
around he was algebra but
i i i would say i'm probably more black
than eric
wow dude we need to have eric even dance
at chris's wedding he did a slow dance
so i was like hey man
i hear the music and eric married white
too
and she's she's tall have you met his
girl i just met her for the first time
at chris rachel dude beautiful lady you
missed the wedding huh huh you missed
the wedding
oh yeah i couldn't go you missed bobby
lee's and chris's right i didn't get
invited to all of them
you got invited to chris's though
i don't know which ones i got invited to
you gotta buy your kisses huh yeah
because i made it yeah
yeah
i'm not sure if that or not you did
i did yeah you do
it was a fun time get that hitter baby
gang baby theo brandon chris eric if
you're there i didn't forget about you
um
brendan chris and erica colorado i was
just going to say this
bring in your girlfriend fishing a lot
of guys don't like to do it
but i do it um that's my girlfriend down
there
what the huh well it didn't work out for
chen
all the way down there
just having a good old time probably
playing with rocks
she's not fishing
so let me know what you guys think um
can get her sting it bringing your
girlfriend fishing
giant buzz buzz
you need to have a girl like hannah bear
yeah with hannah baron hannah baron dude
she gets [ __ ] elbow deep in those
catfish no she's not she's not married
she married a catfish maybe
she made no human though
yeah hannah baron's beautiful man i
think i'll go fishing with her
but she'll be underwater the whole time
it's true that's true
elbow deep girl i'll deep soap to shut
up bro oh brendan get all buddy girl ooh
i'm all muddy
i'm covered in mud hannah we got a large
latte for prancer
when it comes up in high heels
[Laughter]
we have fenty whipped cream only for
prancer
oh yeah she got stuck she was landlocked
on national catfish day and and she
couldn't cat if she couldn't go those
catfish were
[ __ ] june 25th
hey y'all i'm hannah baron today is june
25th which is national catfish day
and i can't be out on the water today
because i got two of my really good
friends that are getting married today
so i'm about to go start getting ready
for that
but
it is national catfish day i wanted to
come on here and say that if y'all seen
my pictures and videos from this year
you probably noticed that instead of my
usual
i don't know
lucky i thought she i think she's a
boyfriend now though yeah she came to
nashville with that boyfriend they're
still together though nice gentleman
though
he's a good guy it's crazy we had hannah
baron and jelly roll in studio at the
same time that's uh oh well
yeah yeah i forgot about that yeah that
was uh on thanksgiving and then jelly on
finally kid last night told that we did
popular [ __ ] 10 p.m but he told us
right after your house because he
brought his brother to the to the studio
scott he brought scott and i was like oh
is your brother a good guy he's like hey
good guy man blah blah did some time and
he goes man after we did the podcast you
and theo on thanksgiving my brother got
all drunk around the family on
thanksgiving took it jumped on the table
took his dick out and pissed on the
turkey
and then apparently this video he's
going to say he was supposed to send us
didn't send it though did y'all wait up
for it or not i was hoping for it i woke
up at 7 00 am text him yo man what that
dick do
damn boy i don't want to see no dig by
my own dick that's my big role i want to
see that nashville big boy piss on that
turkey man you weird man
dude i remember when i was young i wrote
i don't want to see no dick but my own
dick you're right with your left hand
yeah i wrote them all up and it came out
here's hannah barron again
there's the latin hail man hey guys this
is tracy roars from honors california
and i am back with the king of stinging
women with shaved heads
let me just say that i am married
to a man
um
29 years of having a lot of really thick
hair i decided to just shave it all off
you and me both um
i will say that i probably won't ever do
it again but it was really awesome to do
it once i always wanted to see what it
would be like and
yeah what do you guys think do i look
kind of edgy and cool or
was it the worst decision i've ever made
no your face too pretty brandon theo
chris and eric love you guys gang gang
buzz
buzz
sword oh yeah if you're ooh she's she
she does look better long hair let's be
frank here but if you're going to shave
your head you got to have a really
pretty face which she does to pull it
off mm-hmm you have that g.i jane look
man that halsey hall's here baddie did
you shave her head
i think um
now you're going the opposite you're not
trying to shave your head you're trying
you're doing a little operation to
get a b i'm getting more hair put in i
think this lady looks i like her i like
her with short hair
i like that's a man
how [ __ ] dare you that's halsey piece
of [ __ ] it is yeah dude i thought that
was james conroe or whatever that kid is
that ethan klein's always trying to
wiggle in
whatever that guy's name is
oh james charles it must feel oh james
i think the lady i like the short hair
yeah it's dope it must be nice too
having all that long
so good
man baby
i'll tell you i mean
he's a beautiful man you know
prancer would be all over that i'm just
saying if you flash these by somebody
really fast they might not have any idea
oh bro i'm two whiskey's deep that's
halsey me and i'm nashville at a bar
yeah josie i'm gonna bring that
gentleman back to your crib man
i don't want that you won't even know
about you looks like i ran too halsey
but i'm just too drunk to know what's
going on
all right with my left hand at home in
the morning
that
one letter different
[Laughter]
uh
king shaving head it must it must feel
nice
uh mark i mean mark has long hair chin
you've shaved your head before have you
shaved yours nick you'd look insane oh
yeah i have a really tiny head i did it
in eighth grade for my school pictures
and it just looked like a phone you do
have a tiny head dude you look like the
uh the bad guys from the mario brothers
movie bring that up you have the same
hat from tomorrow i see it yep i know
what you're talking about um i think
would you ever shave your head through i
had to shave when i was young me too oh
i was fighting i shaved
there's nick
[Laughter]
there's when he wins
nick when wins his draftkings parley
this weekend
happy [ __ ]
looks like yeah i'm trying to win two
fifths of my head back on odesumi or in
an hour
[Laughter]
when i was a freshman in football the
the helmet they couldn't find one small
enough for me so they had to take a
middle school helmet which was white and
they spray painted it gold but every
time i got hit like chunks would come
out of it and it was like it was white
people and the seniors would like drop
penises on it it was
been tragic for you no it was fun it was
good times i handled it well i think
i don't know what happened that's
hilarious that girl's a dime though with
a shaved head yeah she's fun yeah
sometimes the kids think i wonder if
it's interesting for the kids if mom has
a shaved head or doesn't have a shaved
head
i don't know if it would be because a
lot of people have kids that have
uh alopecia cancer
or don't have any hair
i don't yeah
but i was wondering if the kids if you
change it up if the kids are not getting
they start calling her dad no her face
is too pretty yeah if you got a manly
mom shaves her head and it's going to be
confusing there you go right there
not handsome
is having any eyebrows
oh
yeah
that's what happened to him
that's kind of cool
charlie villanueva he was the first
person with alopecia
before will smith's wife was crying
about it and she doesn't even have it i
don't think she does either i don't
think she has it unreal that's like all
these celebrities they fake some disease
and i'm a big machine gun kelly fan but
he told this [ __ ] story to sell his
[ __ ] documentary so he got a shotgun
in my mouth i loaded i pulled the
trigger but it got jammed and i was
telling tim kennedy that and he's like
that's not how shotguns work
he's like a shotgun expert he's like
that whole story never happened he's
like the gun the bullet doesn't work
like that i was like i [ __ ] knew it
trying to sell that yeah and how's your
name machine on kelly if you can't even
use one
well
to his defense it was a machine gun he
was trying to shoot himself with but
still then you've got a different gun
name yeah your name's shotgun kelly yeah
yeah shotgun kelly's dope jack and
kelly's all right shotgun vaughn what
how come it's not bad
jump off building vaughn
i don't like that one as much
yeah
what's up slava my not shop theogon
castlevania delia
and peter griffin
i got to climb my hand for you guys
and it came out
this cleo
it's a
here pit bull mix moo moo pit bull
whatever you want to call it oh it's
about mackenzie
she's the [ __ ] i'm not cleo i'll say hi
i can't even sting it taking a dog to
the creek
don't stick slow
get a little exercise in
what do you guys think can you stink not
the best swimmer i've seen
but the dog yeah she kind of was pretty
hesitant to get in the water i like a
nice pit though it's my favorite dog i
think a dog likes going down there oh
yeah cool off in the water oh yeah i was
at a house party and they go you like
dogs oh yeah man they go check out this
dog and they i walk in the garage and
they shut the door behind me it was a
cane corso about 170 pound king corso
wow snake
giant dog oh wow they they used to use
them in [ __ ] rome to like kill lions
and [ __ ] oh my god really 170 pound
black pull it up chin king corso they
look nuts pull it up without any paprika
on it you know what i'm saying
yeah it's like that black one there with
the horns that's it right there
[Music]
that's like the dog from the sand lot
that's a different that dog from the
sand i feel what it is but it's not a
king course but that dog's [ __ ] huge
dude
and they can kill lions yeah they still
use them in rome back in the day to kill
lions
great
the best guard dog you can have the
issue is they only respect the family
anybody else is [ __ ] really [ __ ]
best guard dog you can get i should
share a room with a damn
cow
and those dogs hate chows they're
horrible top five
they bite the most humans ciao tell us
chin tell us about it
chaos yeah dude tell us about a chow how
hard i mean skin that thing i no i don't
i've never skinned one when my buddy
actually owned a bunch of them and they
were to me they were disgusting they
kept drooling everywhere shedding st
they stink like stink yeah
can you guess which dog bites the most
humans
number one
um i would say you would bring this up
chin
the dog that buys the most humans
what breed of dog bites the most humans
golden retriever
chihuahua wow
[ __ ] hate little chihuahua but does
that even count though hell yeah dude i
was terrified as a kid of one
friend leon had one i'll eat that
[ __ ] chihuahua like a little wing
like a little drummette
i wonder a chihuahua though oh this
looks like my friend what's his name
prancer i don't remember uh this guy
this is a big promo for this past
weekend at mike perry but uh he's got a
debate club
what's up gang gang renee sosa here out
of 10th planet bethlehem shout out eddie
bravo boom what's up theos up everybody
um just had a debate club for you guys
um hanging out in some nature out here
getting some sunlight
on pennsylvania um
but yeah i wanted to ask theo i heard
you just had mike perry on your podcast
who is your favorite guest that you've
had on your podcast um one of my
favorites you've had is riff raff
um and also
um eddie eddie was always like a killer
on your podcast super funny
i have a suggestion for your podcast uh
his name is the official sewer rat he's
about to drop a music video with um
riffraff also
i get off theo's nuts
everybody else in the room but there he
actually said uh included in his
submission that he trained with you and
he forgot to mention that in his
video academy in beverly hills oh
probably uh gracie academy
very badass you missed training over
there ever uh
those were fun days yeah beverly hills
was cool i missed training in uh
torrance at the grace academy with
hannah and all the most fun man it was
every saturday morning it was at 7 00 am
before like the regular class started
we'd do a black belt class it was like
the lead of the elite like crone gracie
um i know casey
i mean i met him yeah i'm good there's
this casey dude who's a black belt leota
machida henner [ __ ] all the grace
each other it's just a black belt free
rolling class man it was fun
did you see this uh brendan no i don't i
don't see social media theo theo punch
uh mike what you let me punch him let me
see
you know i just stay ready for my
opportunities to to put these paws on
[ __ ] i want to [ __ ] punch
somebody you punch me
punch me bro it's cool bro
i mean the face might i might bleed so
no you could do like a belly shot do you
think i could do i could do pretty
probably pretty good you think
i'm not mad as outfit
mike perry's a good dude yeah yeah i
just i don't think mike gary realizes
how much people like him because he's
reading comments
yeah he mentioned a couple times the
haters i don't think he realized people
i mean i was i didn't realize how
excited i was to see mike perry i think
there's just something about him oh he's
a bad pajama yeah and i think he just
seems like the realest dude like
whatever's going on he just shares what
it is you know he's a guy too you know
he has a kid now so he grew up so he's
not doing all that wild [ __ ] outside the
octagon yeah that's what he said you
know it's tough for him too because he
like you don't want to gain experience
in the ufc and unfortunately for him
like
he had to learn the hard way about being
a professional i think having a kid
helps him out
i mean he's a good dude man i i hate
that he's fighting michael venom paige
i love it he's getting payday probably
and he just wants to brawl
i i think i i'm lean towards your side
if i had the wager uh and you're betting
man nick but i'm just saying he had to
wager
yeah you've already weighed yourself
do you want to bet nick if my heart goes
opposite of no i'm saying i lean towards
yourself um dude my heart's with mike
all day so that's when i don't bet i
don't like conflicting
do you hate money or not
evidently yeah um now i might do a fight
campaign for this if you're in town oh
interesting yeah can we see some michael
van impe just a couple of one of his
last fights maybe just in uh yeah if you
haven't watched michael van page he is a
[ __ ] savage his only like achilles
heel
is um
wrestling mike perry paul daley wrestled
him which is a bad side that was one of
the worst fights ever
just highlights
no michael van page is [ __ ] savage
dude fast
oh
freak dude that time he broke cyborg's
skull and then he faked through a poke
ball nuts adam nuts
okay
now i would say uh mike perry has a
power advantage if he can land extremely
tough for him to land this dude really
doesn't get hit theo
and it's striking
him though it's punching only uh yeah i
know the dude has professional boxing i
do know i only do punches i know he has
no leg watches
he's professional boxing in his past too
this highlight
sucks yeah out of all the highlights to
microphone and
page yeah it's more about like showing
off
now he he's the guy that the bell tour
wants to be champion it's just
grappling's a little tough for him then
why is he in bkfc now
because uh scott coker who i love was
like yeah go do it
yeah i'm thinking about doing a beer is
that colby covington no it looks like
him though boom
what he hit him with that look at him
and he's acting like he's all wobbly
he's so fun to watch
british cat
now he uh
yeah i might do a fight campaign for it
and i talked to poirier yesterday oh can
we hear me for that
don't be scared don't be scared that'd
be sick dude yeah wow but he can't do no
kicks or no acrobats i know you keep
saying that mike
no i get watch mike's fight then let's
go see mike
oh my god some brawls man
watch mike on a bkfc
he had the fight against lane i think it
was
oh julie elaine
mike like to ponch he's a puncher
oh he's like get hit and punch yes
yeah mike's a savage that'd be a fun
fight he's bill for this yes
right he's right where he needs to be
so i'm just curious here how that man
uh it's gonna be interesting yeah my
heart wants mike to win
that's it that's the show yeah
or original crew back in action dodge
and i'll be in action fort wayne indiana
july 14th to the 16th and the following
weekend july 21st to 24th i'm in san
diego at the laugh factory and then the
trash panda summer tour ends in
baltimore august 4th through the 6th
appleton wisconsin just got added
september 8th through the 10th houston
boston it's all on there thickboy.com
y'all
amen and i don't have any more tour
dates i don't know if i'm gonna put any
up for a while i'm taking a break and um
just been taking care of myself and
taking trying to take less things off of
my plate that's why i've been in here
that much uh i'm so glad you hit me up
through the show today man yeah me too
man it was fun miss you guys too
uh
yeah subscribe to the patreon too
just been taking it easy man but nothing
personal i miss you guys and i love you
all we all love you guys now go
subscribe to patreon gang gang baby buzz
buzz oh what is it sore a bull mastiff
they can [ __ ] bull massive is what was
in uh
sandlot really yes wow
my buddy used to draw pictures of some
of those dogs [ __ ] when we were young
hell yeah dude good artist too shout out
to prancer james richard i think was no
his name was uh
was his name james he used to do bonsai
trees too in our town sounds like a
talented gentleman oh very talented his
grandmother dated my father back in the
30s
well in the other 30s in the past sure
all right fort wayne you're up july 14
16. see you guys love you bye
[Music]
how many times i gotta make this song
hey hold on what is this now y'all wanna
switch
[Music]
wait a
minute think
it's the king and the sting in the wing
let's go
legendary trio bringing chris and theo
what you mean you know it's the king and
the sting and the wing
you